[Music]
hey you guys
it's wednesday it's our last live
matinee of the week yeah
we are here yes we are trying to keep
everybody cheerful
it'll be fine okay just chill out yeah i
can't have he's
exciting [ __ ] news today i'm just
[ __ ] man
i'm just trying to keep my mouth shut
during all this [ __ ] yeah you should
[Laughter]
just saying i was right i was right i
knew this would happen
yeah you think it's gonna get worse okay
that's all i'm gonna say
see i told you not to i said before we
came on i was like keep just because
he's just like
my spider senses i was like look we got
a [ __ ] show to do
i can't it's like i got other [ __ ] i got
to do i can't like be sitting here all
day and you're going off on these days
i've just seen this before this was part
of my job
i've seen this before and i'm [ __ ]
terrified let's get on the [ __ ] i'm
terrified people
okay let's go ahead and let's go ahead
and go i'm not it's fine i'm just
getting that feeling that i used to get
yeah but
okay don't worry about it all right
that's gonna happen you're gonna keep
you're gonna keep me sane right
yeah okay i said no it's gonna happen
all right calm down okay i'm good
all right so uh as we said yesterday
netflix just added a delightful little
series called the history of swear words
yeah it's good it's good it's good
because um
it's actually like just like a really
fun light kind of series it's only six
episodes
they got the right guy hosting it the
episodes are only like 20
25 minutes long something like that and
each one
focuses on a different swear word yeah
now i don't know if they're gonna do any
more i mean nicholas cage
nicholas cage was absolutely the perfect
person to host this because he
is just it's so so fun i mean he's just
like really really good in this he just
cages the [ __ ] out
but i also like too that they almost
have it
like the set that they have at the
beginning almost looks like some like
masterpiece theater kind of [ __ ] or
something like that
but then he just and a lot of the times
he's very
serious but also kind of jokey like at
the same time but it's like a really
really good tone and then like every now
and then he just like goes crazy on the
[ __ ] and it's really really funny
i mean there's other good [ __ ] on there
too they have like a lot of funny like
comedians um
you know on there they have like sarah
silverman's on there baron von
who's on the new uh mystery science
theater i think he does servo on the new
one
and like you know they have all these
other people uh nick offenberg or
whatever his name is okay
and there's a couple other um comedians
and so
and then they have like experts and
stuff too it's not
real it's kind of educational but
it's pretty comedic yeah it's it's kind
of just more meant to be
funny it does tell you like some cool
facts about some of the words and like
where maybe they came from but it's like
it's not super in-depth it's obviously
it's just light entertainment yeah it's
raunchy yeah
it's funny as hell but really the star
of this show is [ __ ] nick cage
they're letting cage cage the [ __ ] out
well that's why they hired him for this
that's why
that's why that's why you watch this
yeah you watch this
to [ __ ] see nick cage just [ __ ]
feed himself man cajun
he cages the [ __ ] up yeah and uh
yeah so that's why i like the series
yeah the other the other comedians it's
kind of hit and miss some of them are
funny some aren't funny but it doesn't
matter you're
it's something you're having a drink
you're tossing back a few and you're
just laughing at them
and like i said the you know there's
only six episodes and they're short so
it's easy i mean i just sat and watched
all of them and it was like nothing it
was just like it took a couple hours
so what they did so the first one um
let's see what did they cover
it was the first one was [ __ ] the second
one was [ __ ] the third one was
[ __ ] then it was dick [ __ ] and then
the last one was damn
which at first i was kind of like why
they choose like such a weak sauce
[ __ ] last word but
in a way it was good because they wanted
to show
because they even addressed that they're
like you know why that's like barely a
curse word
but that was kind of like the um the
point they were trying to make was that
you know back in the middle ages if you
damned someone it was like the worst you
know what i mean that was like the worst
thing you could say to somebody else
and now it's like not even a curse word
anymore so they're kind of they were
kind of showing like the evolution of
curse word because the one guy that was
on there i can't remember who's like a
lexa
lexa lexicographer or whatever like or
an etymologist or something like that
and he was talking about he said where
damn
is now where it's like you wouldn't even
get upset probably if you're like
four-year-old said it
it's like that's probably where [ __ ]
will be like in 20 years it's like no
one's really going to care that much
anymore
it's getting there i feel like [ __ ] is
getting there too because
it's it's interesting too they go a
little bit into
um you know especially like on the damn
show they were talking the damn show
that damn show
they were talking about gone with the
wind which came out in 1939 and how it
was this massive massive deal
for clark gable to say i don't give a
damn at the end
and how the dude had to go to like the
haze code
you know to the haze guy at the you know
at the office
i was like hey it was in the book can we
please put it in the movie because they
weren't going to let them
and so it's just funny to see how far
along the words have come
but yeah it's like i really i thought
this was like a super fun show and like
i said there was
uh the dick show i think was the
funniest um i don't know the [ __ ] show
was pretty funny too
the dick one was funny because um
interestingly fun trivia dick is the
only
uh curse word that actually started out
as a name
you know what i mean and so they were
pointing out
they're like it's really funny because
you can say dick on tv
if it's someone's name but if you're
talking about
a dick like if you're calling someone a
dick or
you know you're referring to someone's
dick then they'll bleep it out
so i just i thought that was very
actually maybe you can call somebody a
dick you just can't
you can't use dick to refer to an actual
dick which i thought was i was like okay
that seems arbitrary
but all right yeah mango said the [ __ ]
one was a great episode too
i really really liked i can't remember
the comedian that said it but she
perfectly encapsulated
the [ __ ] conundrum which is
she was basically like um okay she's
like my close
girlfriends she's like hell even my
grandma can go hey [ __ ] what's up or
something like that she's like if a man
calls me a [ __ ]
i'm gonna burn his [ __ ] house down i
like how the series i like how the
series also pointed out that there's a
difference between the united states and
the uk when it comes to swearing you
could say anything in the uk
in the united states especially like in
bible belt south back in the 80s and 90s
and actually a bit today if you're
around the wrong person and you say any
of these words freely in public they'll
[ __ ] attack you
they're like what'd you say you know i
mean did you take the lord's name vayne
you know they'll do that or they'll
which is hilarious you spoke that way in
front of my wife that you know it's like
you go it's like going back to the early
1900s
they take it as a personal insight i
know a few people like that still but
they're very old
yeah i ran into that last time i was in
mississippi you know
really that was only a couple years ago
a couple years back and like uh i forgot
what the way some people in mississippi
were because it seems like most people
just swear without even thinking about
it yeah you know
it doesn't register yeah i was in
hattiesburg which is
one of their bigger towns and i was like
oh oh yeah yeah sorry about that i
forgot you know
oh my god that you guys are provincial
but you know what i mean it's just
i would never i wouldn't have just like
i would have just not been able to it's
not
everybody though it's it's it's not
everybody
i can't tell you elsewhere it's it's
it's their point it's their it's their
way of virtue signaling you know what i
mean that they're that they're good
people
yeah well that's that's really dumb you
know what i mean that's
what's with the kind of people i come
from but you know what i mean they're
just but that's the kind of people that
they get all
they get all uptight about swearing but
then they'll do horrible [ __ ]
well somebody they won't say horrible
[ __ ] not all of them but some of them
are like that
which i think is very silly and honestly
i think that
you know studies that have done
obviously this is a generality but
studies that have been done
show that people that swear a lot tend
to be more honest
yeah you know i mean tend to like lie
less um
and also they talked a little bit too
about like the science of swearing like
where it comes from in your brain
because it's not like the same place the
thing is though is that they're not
they're not offended that you swore
in front of them they're they get
offended that you swore in front of one
of their family members like it
embarrassed them
it's that kind of [ __ ] that's right
that's a weird way of doing it but
i'd be like [ __ ] i'm not offended yeah
that was like
your grandparents your grandparents you
know what i mean [ __ ] like your
grandparents were like
well it's not my grandparents because my
grandma used to swear all the time
it's just it's really funny because i
was
i guess maybe because i was like a good
little kid
i didn't really swear until i was a
teenager
like when i was you know 10 or 11 i was
i would swear and then i'd be like oh
you know what i mean which but which is
dumb because my parents and grandparents
absolutely did not care
if i swore and they swore all the time
and it wasn't really
so it wasn't like don't say that they
you know i never had that
it's just that that was a me thing i
don't really know why but then
you know i i'm so that may be why i
swear so much now is because i was like
making up for it but um there was
something else i wanted to say too about
about it god damn it oh what i was gonna
say when because you said about the uk
i was kind of hoping that they would do
a [ __ ] show
or or a [ __ ] or a [ __ ] show it could be
two words
although i like that you know but the
thing about it is that [ __ ] if you say
that in the
u.s that is something very different
well no
it doesn't mean anything different
necessarily but it's way more offensive
in the u.s than it is in the uk or
australia from my understanding
and honestly it's still very much
gendered here if you call somebody i've
never heard anybody in the us call a man
a [ __ ] yeah but in the uk in the uk and
australia they do even though it still
means the same thing
um you know everybody knows what what
that's a slang term before who's this
that particularly targeted at women it's
like
it's like seven steps above [ __ ] yeah
that's way worse than that
oh my god if you call a woman that you
are getting punched right in there yeah
she might try to sue you
yeah so it's so it's way more offensive
i mean i think it will go
the way of i mean i think that only one
person
said it on the i think it was one of the
female comedians
i think it was on the [ __ ] show and
because they were talking about how
obviously originally [ __ ] came from cat
and then it was you know there was like
some word play with you know
female vagina or whatever and then as it
went on it started to refer to that
but and and you know even in the 1800s
there were like [ __ ]
can-can shows and stuff like that they
were called like the pussycat thing and
like
they'd lift up their skirts and there'd
be cats underneath there and [ __ ] like
that so they did all that kind of stuff
but
um one of the comedians said in there
that she said she didn't call her cat a
[ __ ] or something like she's like i
call her a [ __ ] or something like that i
was like okay
but that was kind of the only time that
they said it i hope that they do more of
these though
i know there's not a lot of uh swear
words left anymore to do but
tammy and sophie are in there saying
that you know like that they have
relatives that you know
will leave the room if there's people
swearing on tv
or people would be comments on videos
it'd be great without all that foul
language and the other stuff no we
do that we do get uh we had to comment
on the show every now and then
yeah um not that often it was much more
early on in the show
but every now and then we i will get
like some grandma or grandpa
on there because i don't know how old
they are but the first couple months of
the show remember we'd have people will
you people stop swearing i have my kids
listening with us
and i'm like this is an r-rated show you
know what i mean please don't you know
don't unsubscribe you know i'm just yeah
this ain't g-rated [ __ ] yeah we
don't have time to censor ourselves
which is going to be just like normal
and like i said if i couldn't swear i
don't think i'd be able to talk
well you know this is not a canned
show it's just a it's a show basically
kind of like among a small click of
people you know and it's just like
we're supposed to be just like online
friends more anything else you know what
i mean
and it was how i came up listening to
the radio back in the day with howard
stern and [ __ ]
i don't like a heavily formatted show
even though we started off like that
but that's because we thought it had to
be you know
yeah but no and then didn't have live
streaming back then
doing it live is so much better because
you can get instant feedback and stuff
yeah that's i think that's what i like
the most about it i mean and that and
the lack of
post editing just us performing to each
other is a lot harder you know what i
mean
on these topics uh but you know if we
have a live active crowd in the comments
yeah who's asking us questions or you
know giving us ideas
well i can also feel the tone of the
audience
at the time i'm not playing to the
recorded audience i'm playing to the
live audience you know i think
jenny probably is too oh absolutely so
you know what i mean it's just
after the show we'll have people in the
you know in the comments listening to
the recording show will you guys please
please stop going off i don't really
care that much about that
no offense because it's the live show
for us that really matters because
that's where all our patrons are
most of them yeah and our big supporters
the thing about it too is that a lot of
shows that i like
um you know it [ __ ] like last podcast on
the left i like half in the bag
stuff like that um where drinking is
kind of part of it
at least in half in the bags case and
going off on tangents is kind of part of
it too
so i mean i kind of enjoy that if i like
the personalities
of the people that are on the show then
i don't really care what they're talking
about
you know what i mean it's like if i want
some informative [ __ ]
then i'll watch like a discovery channel
dog or a history channel documentary
some [ __ ] like that if i want to see
something without
a bunch of different digressions right
then i'll just watch that i'm going to
watch some youtube [ __ ]
you just take me on a journey yeah when
you start when we started doing the live
streams that was around the beginning of
the pandemic and
man it was a lot easier because it felt
like we promised to walk you guys
through the damn apocalypse
i didn't know the apocalypse was going
to be [ __ ] 20 30 years long
this shit's going to keep your phone
going let's not you
i'm 20 30 years long yes no i wasn't
going to say your jinx and i was like
you're
you're wildly exaggerating is what
you're doing that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm seeing and this could be
forever no it's not
it's gonna be fine just stop
exaggerating stop being such a little
[ __ ]
all right we'll see we'll see how it
goes
but yeah i'm kind of hoping you know
what would be awesome okay they
absolutely need to do a [ __ ] show they
should do a [ __ ] show
although that one's not i feel like [ __ ]
is not all that common
um actually nowadays i hear twent more
than twice
it's like [ __ ] and con like together um
i hear i hear it more i heard it more in
the uk but they say [ __ ] and that's
as far as i know it's not really
gendered either because that's usually
anybody you're just calling somebody
like it's calling somebody a dick or an
[ __ ] or something like that or an
idiot
so it's kind of like that you know what
would be awesome is if they did
an episode about the best swears from
other countries
because they did go like slightly into
that they had like three or four
examples of like really crazy
like uh swears from another from other
countries like there was a south african
one and there was like a german one or
something like i can't remember what
they were
but i was like that would be cool if
they did a whole episode or two about
that uh but as far as it is they're just
focusing on the english language
ones and like i said other than cotton
[ __ ] i can't really think of any other
i mean [ __ ] but i mean that was
kind of covered on the [ __ ] show
you know cause yeah on the [ __ ] show
they kind of went into like you know
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what i mean there's all
the different like iterations of it
so i don't know they'll they'll run out
of cuss words eventually i'm gonna say
that's like
we're really like the pool of them is
getting really small it looks like it
was set up for
two seasons probably maybe i mean they
could talk about [ __ ] even though
that's not really that bad of a word
either there's all kinds of you know
other ones they can do yeah
i can't even really think of anything i
can't even really think of anything else
other than
like slurs yeah which probably would
that be some problematic
[ __ ] to like wade into but i don't know
like i said it's just
it's just a fun little series
just you know to have a cocktail and
watch nicolas cage
caging out and watching a bunch of
comedians swearing and coming up with a
bunch of funny [ __ ]
and it has like some great little
animation sequences and [ __ ] like that
too
so that's pretty cool all right so you
done
yeah it's about time we gotta uh give
beijing her little
yeah liver pill yeah because it's time
to do that
and i have some other stuff i gotta do
so
thanks everybody for dropping by on this
wednesday uh
it's recorded shows tomorrow and friday
and then we'll see you guys again live
on saturday for the main episode
we'll have a drink we'll talk about some
real depressing [ __ ]
it'll be a good time so we'll see you
guys on saturday
bye